Let's once again see
if we can order now
a different set of decimals
from least to greatest,
and once again I encourage
you to pause this video
and try to do this on your own.
So let's go to the most
significant place, the ones
place here.
None of these have any ones.
So then we can go to the
next most significant place,
which is the tenths place.
This has five tenths.
This has six tenths.
This has one tenth.
This has five tenths.
So if we just look at the
tenths place, the ones that
have the fewest tenths--
this has only one tenth,
this one only has one tenth,
this one has five tenths,
this one has five tenths, and
then this one has six tenths.
So I've ordered it by what's
going on in the tenths place.
Now, both of these have
the same number of tenths.
Let's move to the
hundredths place
to figure out which
of these is larger.
This one has six hundredths.
This has five hundredths,
so this one is larger.
It has more hundredths.
Same number of tenths,
more hundredths.
And hundredths
are obviously more
significant than
thousandths, so it
doesn't matter which one
has the more thousandths.
It matters that this
one has more tenths,
and actually this one has
more thousandths as well.
But now let's go
look at these two.
These have the same
number of tenths.
They both have five tenths.
But this one has six
hundredths, while this one only
has two hundredths,
so this one is larger.
And then finally,
this one of course,
had six tenths, so this
one had the most tenths.
So we don't even have to look
at the other places here.
And we're done.